sport machen zu hause das ist einer der
trends solange die fitnessstudios in
deutschland geschlossen sind
max ist trainer in berlin eigentlich
gibt der kurse zu kroner zeiten macht
der live streams auf instagram ich stehe
normalerweise vor einer gruppe
unterricht eine gruppe guckt dabei in
gesichter und der situation geschuldet
jetzt muss man auch hier kreativ sein
und irgendwie eine neue lösung dafür
finden
und die sieht für jeden anders aus
familienzeit streichen backen oder
musizieren die neuentdeckung der eigenen
vier wände hunderttausendfach online
geteilt unter dem hashtag wir bleiben zu
hause auch von max ob flow wirklich
mitgemacht hat eine nutzerin kommentiert
jedenfalls also ich liege in meinem bett
und esse chips um die zu bekommen hilft
normalerweise der gang in den supermarkt
doch dort herrscht das leere regale
glaubt man millionen uploads in den
sozialen medien radio moderatorin und dj
larissa ries wurde das ganze zu viel
jeder postet gerade leere regale und
regt sich wahnsinnig darüber auf dass
begünstigt der eigentlich nur dass die
regale noch leere und dann habe ich
gedacht na komm lass uns doch einfach
mal volle regale posten
gesagt getan der hashtag volle regale
macht die runde
bei den nudeln essen fast alles da
bei den dosen bundesweit von nutzern
verwendet für etwas beruhigung in
unruhigen zeiten
eine besonders außergewöhnliche idee hat
finn kliemann musiker webdesigner und
wie er selbst sagt internet nur beim
musik video zu seiner neuen single
scheint sich die ganze welt nur um ihn
zu drehen
dabei ist kliemann lediglich vorlage für
seine fans und follower also der plan
war möglichst viele menschen in einem
musikvideo zu vereinen aber da wir uns
gerade für sich treffen können muss das
von zu hause passieren
das heißt jeder konnte in seinem
wohnzimmer seiner küche oder was auch
immer einfach nur mit dem stuhl
teilnehmen zehntausende machen dass sie
suchen sich eine szene des musikvideos
heraus und stellen sie nach
die fotos werden von kliemann ins video
montiert mit achtung folgendem ergebnis
eine schillernde szenerie ein mensch
ausfiel
erschaffen durch eine online
gemeinschaft die in zeiten von sozialer
distanz zusammenrückt gar nichts mehr
wissen mit x 2 karten
den wichtigsten dingen des lebens
mein leben war
platz